salut c'est audrey lamy je suis de
nouveau lucide en moi moche et méchant 3
alors vous allez voir dans le film go
balthazar brad les minions agnès va être
obligé de gagner est énorme scoop
gru un frère jumeau qui s'appelle dont
je vous laisse voir la bande annonce
j'ai peur d'en avoir dit un peu trop là
non gad le diamant a été volé avez vous
pu laisser battre face à prat s'échapper
vous attirez c'est trop bien lui faire
des câlins aux news qu'est ce que tu
fais comme tu as pu te réveille je vends
mes jouets excusez moi avec plaisir et
bien comme je vous le disais au revoir
encore lui je dois vraiment qu
entretenir avec vous à la demande de
votre frère jumeau crew quoi un frère
jumeau que fujimori blues m
[Musique]
j'ai trop hâte de rencontrer mon corps
ne pas aimer regarder l'heure mais tu
ferais mieux avec toujours là où il est
pas content vous devez être sa
merveilleuse épouse jamais cet endroit
est impressionnant moi c'est pas mal je
ne laisse pas vraiment d'importance aux
choses
le clou nous avons la méchanceté dans le
sang ses global boobs tu es fait appel
fait tuer la tradition familiale
toi et moi non je laissais 7,8 derrière
moi
[Musique]
c'est parti
tout va bien
[Musique]
tran patil qu'on va redevenir méchant
tout cas bio
wen pin groupe wahaha chez nous
l'éteignoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]